[Music]
Alain Chou, for those of
you who aren't yet familiar with
the internal organization of
special services, particularly the French special services,
the Security Intelligence Service
is responsible for
gathering intelligence and implementing
active measures outside the
national territory in matters of
counter-crime, counter-espionage, counter-
proliferation, and
counter-terrorism. All of this involves quite
recreational activities that take place
abroad, so obviously in complete
illegality
and in the utmost secrecy. And it
gives the world a somewhat
[Music]
specialized view.
Mr. Chou, hello, hello. I'm
interviewing you today for a
website called
Serview. It's a website that gives
people who are
n't heard enough the opportunity to express themselves. We'd like to
get your perspective on the situation,
your level of
expertise in the field, on current events.
Well, first of all, I'm
not particularly looking to be
heard; I think I'm heard enough as it is
through a number of
From conference papers, I do indeed have
some ideas, a bit
unorthodox, about
Syria because I'm not part of
the mainstream. This doesn't mean
I support the current
regime, which I know well
since my first trips to Syria
date back to 1966 and I've been going there
regularly for 40 years. I'm
perfectly aware that the
Syrian regime is a brutal, authoritarian,
and rather undemocratic regime.
The simple question I ask myself,
and to which I'm seeking answers, is
whether the current opposition and
rebellion truly embody
democratic values ​​and are
capable of
establishing a political system comparable to
ours, at least in terms of
freedom and human rights. For now, I don't
see any sign
of this openness within the
Syrian rebellion. What can you
tell us about the financing and arming of the
Syrian rebellion? Well, regarding the
financing of the Syrian rebellion,
I think everyone knows more or less what's going on
today.  The situation is clear,
since the financiers themselves haven't
hidden what they were doing. The
Emirate of Qatar and
Saudi Arabia have clearly claimed to have
financially and
militarily supported the rebellion. The South Korean
special services, the General
Intelligence
Directorate, acknowledges having been
behind the creation of Jabhat Nusra,
the Victory Front, which claims allegiance to
the Al-Qaeda organization, even though this
organization has become quite
elusive. Jabhat Nusra, therefore, created
by the South Koreans, clearly claims
its membership in the
violent international Islamic movement. It has,
moreover,
been classified as a
terrorist organization by
the American administration, which has
recently undertaken a number of
measures against this
organization, which remains the
main armed opposition organization
to the current regime. What
can you tell us about France's position
on the Syrian conflict? Well, I have
a little trouble following France's position, given what
we've seen very recently.  Fifteen days
apart, the President of the
Republic initially proposed
arming the Syrian rebellion, even though
the international community
opposed it, only to then, fifteen days
later, say he wouldn't arm the
rebellion because he had no
guarantee of knowing where the
weapons would end up. So it's a rather dubious policy.
I can clearly see that it
fundamentally consists of
supporting the Syrian uprising and
rebellion, but one that doesn't seem to
know who to
turn to in order for this support to be
effective and lead to
democratic or liberal reforms. What's the way
out of this conflict? For now, I don't
see any. This conflict has been going on for
two years, which demonstrates
that the current regime
still has popular support, because
no dictatorship without
popular support can withstand two years of
armed rebellion—
two years of civil war.
Since it is indeed a civil war we are dealing with, it has
caused such
destruction, both in terms of the
economic viability of the state, that
things will never be the same again.
This power, the power in place, has
lost much of its
legitimacy and its capacity
for command,
administration, and governance.
For the moment, the only possible way
out we see is either the
long-term prolongation of a
Lebanese-style civil war, which would see
ethnic and religious communities clashing, or a
partition of the country into different ethnic and religious entities: the
Alawites, the Drus, the Ismailis, the
Christians, and the Sunni Muslims, and
then the Kurds as well, who are beginning to
demonstrate, as in Iraq, a desire for
autonomy or even independence.
Russia, China—well, Russia,
Russia—I believe that
Russia's primary motivation in
its support, not for Syria,
but for the
established international order, stems from the fact that
the French and the British have very
largely  They exceeded the mandate they
received from the
United Nations in Libya, where the
French and British were
mandated to protect civilian populations from
heavy-arm repression by the government in power.
However, they significantly
exceeded this mandate by arming the
rebellion,
diplomatically recognizing it, bombing the
palaces and the entire Libyan state apparatus, and finally, having the
Libyan leader lynched with the help of their
detection system, which allowed them to
locate him and then deliver him to a
mob in front of television cameras.
Neither the Russians nor the Chinese
want the UN to become a
machine for assigning good and bad
governance scores and allowing
Western coalitions to
militarily eliminate regimes they
dislike. That, I
think, is the primary reason why
China and Russia are dragging their feet
and opposing
a number of
international intervention decisions
in Syria. For Russia, there are...
Others cite the protection of
Orthodox minorities. I don't really believe
that Russia is motivated
by arms sales to
Syria, since Syria has never paid for the
weapons Russia supplies, nor by
strategic considerations of a
deep-water port in the Mediterranean, which is
a closed sea.
The
position of the United States has appeared
fluctuating over the last
two or three years. It's clear
that initially, the United States,
like France and
Great Britain, supported the
Syrian rebellion, denounced the
Syrian regime, and called for its
overthrow.
Now, realizing that the
Syrian political opposition is extremely
unstable, marginalized, and has no
authority over the military apparatus, and
that the Free Syrian Army
is completely neutralized by the
Turkish Islamist party, leaving room
only for the armed Islamic movement
claiming to be jihadist...
Americans are starting to
question their commitment and
even to undertake a number of
military actions against these
jihadist movements across
Jordan, Israel, and so on. So I don't really know
where
the Obama administration is going during this
second term. It's clear that at the
end of Obama's first term,
the American administration, with Hillary
Clinton as head of the
State Department, supported the Syrian rebellion.
It seems much less obvious to me
today, and I think we need to
try to discern in the
coming weeks or months what
the options will be for both the
State Department and the
Pentagon regarding the
Syrian rebellion. Can you
tell us a little about the affair? The affair
is a matter of, I would say,
law enforcement and
domestic policy, on which I'm not really
qualified to speak. I
consider the affair to be much more of a
psychiatric case than a case of
international terrorism. I don't see a
fundamental difference
between the Mera affair, the
Mera drift, and that  From someone like Anders
Brević in Norway or Timothy Mveg
in the United States, the guy who carried out
the Clom City attack, I think it's
a psychiatric case. It's
like Anders Brević, he's a
man who needed to rationalize
his delusions, his violent delusions, his
delusions of revolt and rebellion, and he
rationalized them by drawing on his
personal cultural background, which is that of the
flamboyance of
jihadist revolt, just as Anders Brević
drew on the old Nazi tradition, the
old European Nazi tradition. But when
people like Claude Guant or
Bernard Squarcini talk about
Mera as a lone wolf, I think they're
absolutely right, much to the chagrin of a
number of
self-proclaimed experts on TV talk shows. They're
absolutely right. It's not because
Mera received support from his family,
help from a friend who lent him a
stolen scooter, and who triggered
The enthusiasm of a hundred idiots on
Facebook makes him, uh, a full-fledged
member of a
violent international jihadist group with a
political agenda and
specific projects. He's a guy who
acted alone. He made two trips, I
believe quite short, to Afghanistan, from which he was
expelled the first time for a
passport issue and from which he had to
leave a second time for
health reasons. He surely
met religious extremists there, but
given the density of religious extremists in
Afghanistan, it's not surprising that he did.
That said, it wasn't on their
instructions that he acted to commit acts
of violence in France that
serve no cause. The
Boston massacre, the Boston massacre, we
are in the same situation in my
opinion, at least subject to further evidence.
Now, with the
Mera investigation, we know enough. It's
possible that, concerning Mera, his
dangerousness was underestimated by the
internal security services.
It's possible that for the two young
men in Boston, it was the  Same thing,
but unless there are
new elements
linking them to a
revolutionary jihadist international,
I think we're also dealing with
individual paths of
revolt and rebellion by
poorly
integrated people who rationalize their
need for violence through their attachment
to a certain form of religion, but
who acted quite individually. One
last word on the
critical thinking of the media: what
can you tell us about their interpretation and
way of presenting
information? Well, if you, I suppose, are
talking about the French media,
or even the European and American media, yes, well,
the American media have a
problem: a kind of
profound ignorance of the rest of the
world and a kind of arrogance
that makes America the
center of everything, and when a problem arises, it's
necessarily
the Americans. Which isn't always true, especially
concerning France.
What I observe a lot
in France is that our media,
particularly our newspapers, but also our
audiovisual media, do a lot  A lot of
moralizing, editorials, and
commentary, and very little
information, and in any case, a lot of
ignoring history,
social contexts, and
cultural contexts,
and conveying a kind of groupthink
and political correctness that they try to
reinforce every day by all pulling
in the same direction, like a school of
fish all moving in the same
direction without really knowing which one,
because you never know who's
leading the school of fish. That's the
credibility of our politicians with the
Libyan, Syrian, and
Egyptian conflicts. What do you think? Well, I
think public opinion isn't too far off the mark. You
should never
mock public opinion, even if
it's basic; it still sees
things clearly. And we can clearly see how much
public opinion misjudges or
struggles to understand the
political options of our various
governments, whether right-wing or
left-wing. I'm not making any
distinctions, since
they've all gotten themselves into the
same problems. What I
observe, however, is that above all,
our  Political choices mean that
French politics is no longer credible anywhere, insofar as
we burn what we once
cherished, we condemn to death people
we invited two years
prior to either march in our
Bastille Day parade in the place of honor or to
pitch their tents in the gardens of a
grand Parisian hotel, only to then call for
their heads to be put on pikes.
Our partners across the
Mediterranean don't quite understand this, and
I believe French public opinion doesn't either.
Indeed, when they see a
President of the
Republic change his mind and opinion
on the support given to the
Syrian rebellion in 15 days, when nothing
spectacular happened in
that 15-day period, our
fellow citizens undoubtedly struggle to
follow the intricacies of our
foreign policy. One last word, some advice
for young people, young people who
might be watching you online: what
can you tell them
regarding their critical thinking? How can they
strengthen, work on, and sharpen their
critical thinking skills? I have  One piece of advice to give them:
learn history, because those who know it, well,
it doesn't explain everything, but
those who don't are
condemned to repeat it. So learn
history,
and there's no magical thinking, there's no
madness. People who do
something do it because they need to in
relation to their
cultural past, their historical past, the
violence they suffered, what they
inflicted on others. And if we do
n't know all of this past, we can't understand
the
present.
[Music]